una tragedia que sigue cobrando vidas
este lunes la secretaría de seguridad de
México informó de una nueva muerte a
causa del incendio en un puesto de
detención migrante de Ciudad Juárez con
el fallecimiento Hacienda 40 el número
de víctimas de los sobrevivientes 23 se
encuentran hospitalizados el migrante
venezolano Edward Caraballo cuentan lo
que vivió durante la conflagración Duré
casi 20 minutos encerrado ahí a poder 5
minutos Llamando a mi familia así me
contestaba Hasta qué día no obviamente
para el baño me metí para el baño me
rompí la cara con mi suéter Edward se
encuentra en Estados Unidos recibiendo
tratamiento médico por sobreexposición
al humo la imagen de su esposa mientras
él luchaba por su vida dio la vuelta al
mundo
y mi esposa me cuenta que en la mulanza
me parece Pero ahí no sentía nada
trataba debby y estaba llorando y hoy
gritadme llorando pero yo no entendía
porque estaba en otro lado pues la
compañera de Edward vinagre Infante
también se encuentra en territorio
estadounidense juntos deben presentarse
ahora ante la autoridad fronteriza hasta
el momento las autoridades mexicanas Han
detenido a cinco personas por los hechos